we can't even have an open conversation
about flat earthers or not but like it's
like okay
people
very dumb and we're also extremely
susceptible right okay
like
any any like war ever right
you have to convince your people that
that that you want to fight something
yeah yeah how do you do that how do you
convince a whole population of people
i don't know ask hitler yeah right but
that's the thing right i believe this
was like really well documented after
world war ii is that like they what if
there's a very small but possible chance
that you have weapons of mass
destruction
yeah
they got a bit of oil
stock prices go boom
do you like driving
i'll i'll find the video like mood and
ask me that was it there was yeah i
watched this video and it was this guy
especially talking about how well after
world war ii yeah a few um
uh jews people who have met fled and a
few scientists who lived in america yeah
they were they wanted to study how
people could go along with like really
bad atrocities in like world war ii
right like your everyday guy like a
normal dude just kind of like sign up
and be like okay we'll we'll do this oh
yeah like the whole ant like the nazi
party yeah yeah how they just kind of
you know and some of the really horrible
stuff how you could convince people that
this was the right thing to do yeah
and it was basically explaining how like
there are like certain traits that one
might have which would make you more
susceptible
to to end up doing something like that
yeah some personality traits it was
really interesting because stuff that
you like you wouldn't think correlates
to you like you think oh i'm really
strong-willed yeah but maybe you like
strong leaders strongly to ask you to do
bad things oh maybe he's justified it in
no way that makes sense right like it's
i think i think we all like to think
that we are like this this imp impet all
sorts of words impenetrable impenetrable
fortress of mind that nobody can affect
our opinion or uh
uh who us to do something that we would
never do yeah i think in reality we're a
long time it happens all the time i mean
i mean there is there is literally an a
psychological experiment that uh details
i can't remember the exact name of the
experience
yeah they see electricity one so it's
the one where
authority it's where it's so they'll
basically they'll uh they'll tell them
that they're zapping you some illness is
it milner's experiment i don't know what
experiments they'll turn up the
electricity because somebody tells them
to do it yeah because they say that it's
like a good but then they have like a
fake person screaming while they're
turning up the electricity yeah and
somebody keeps telling them to keep
doing it and they keep doing it because
because a doctor or an authority figure
is telling them to keep doing so so it's
basically like fake squid game right so
you're you're put into a room
why don't you have to
this is probably like the deepest debate
we were ever having and god is like it's
kind of like a society we live in
you could have just said liar game you
know
basically the whole thing is framed as a
memory exercise right okay so you the
person who's being who's the uh being
experimented on basically uh you're told
that you're gonna take part in a memory
exercise and you're gonna sit in a room
with a person next to you and one of you
is going to be the person learning and
one of you is going to be the tester
right and so what you're told is that um
if you are given an electric shock if
you get an answer wrong then in theory
then you should be a better learner
because you're you're doing like shock
therapies yourself that's what you're
told obviously that's complete [ __ ]
because this experiment's got nothing to
do with uh memory right so
one of you by chance
is
is the learner one of you
is the teacher or the experimenter
or the teacher but in reality you're
going to be given the teacher right
because you're the only person who's
actually being experimented on yeah
right and so the other person who is the
learner goes in another room
and
you have to uh you have to give them a
memory quiz right and the point the
problem is they're going to get it wrong
and that's part of the design of the
experiments right and you're shown
you're you're you're given
you're given a taste of what the
electric shock that they're going to be
feeling feels like right and it's like
on the lowest level yeah right and so as
as this experiment goes on originally
they get the questions right and then
they get one answer wrong and so you
have to administer them an electric
shock yeah and they feel like pain right
and you hear them feel free you don't
see it but you hear them in another room
even though it's just a pre-recording
yeah um and then as they get more
questions wrong
um the scientist tells you to up the
voltage and administer the shock right
and they keep getting it wrong right and
so the scientist keeps telling you to up
the voltage and keep administering this
electric shock until to a point where
like they are [ __ ] screaming out in
agony or you can hear them on the
speaker screaming out in agony and then
it gets to a point when it's just
silence right right and it's just
silence and then um the scientist keeps
telling you stop the voltage i'm voting
keep going keep going and like the
amount of people who even though you
know they were
totally uncomfortable with the fact that
they could hear someone screaming from
the fact that they were administering
administering this electric shock and it
still went silent they went all the way
up to the end and they still
administered like the most high voltage
in their mind electric shock experiment
because we trust authority figures
and and like it just proved that
a lot of a lot of people more like you
know
the majority of people will be willing
to listen to a person who they view as a
as an authority figure yeah to tell them
to do something even if it's like a
battle if it goes against what they
believe even if it's a horrible act and
it's it's uh it's a very interesting
psychological experiment
um i mean it could be turned into a
squid game that's what i said this kind
of sounds like a squid
thing it kind of sounds like a squid
game the writers for season two i'll
like write that down this literally has
nothing to do with squid games squidward
season two milgram's experiment this has
nothing to do with squid games
i want to see milgram's experiment in
squid game season 2
but it's like actually a shock but they
actually die yeah
no but like see that's that's just goes
to show how
you know there's so many people who say
like i'm not gullible
but we all are to a certain degree
because we i feel we constantly get told
to do things that originally go against
what we believe in or you know are very
easily persuaded by just someone even if
they don't have that much of an
authoritative uh you know
vibe about them to just be like oh well
i mean this person who in my mind is
more authoritative about this particular
subject than i am maybe i should just
trust them yeah like the whole fact that
you know we have a [ __ ] a literal
audience of people who will probably
change their mind about something we say
on this show or something we see on our
own channels
you know seem like an amazing they're
like yeah this if so if i say so and so
anime sucks there's probably a number of
people who are like yeah you know what
he's probably right even though i have
zero authority over that person right
it's just scary because and and i know
that happens because it's hap it's the
opposite has happened to me as well
where
all of us yeah it happens to all of us
you know that's the reason why we have
conflict because people are good at
persuading people yeah it's it's like
i feel like we're just breaking down the
most fundamental problem about humanity
it's like you're not me
we've had like three deep conversations
on three episodes in a row now that's a
deep taste now this is like deep
tortoise deep taste
deep taste
we went from [ __ ] to this
is deep in fancy font
yeah that sounds so
gross gross